- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians.
Today we're going to be
discussing more irregular plurals.
So, this is the irregular
plural part II, the two-ening.
Because we really want to
focus on this en particle.
I'll explain in a minute.
So, previously we discussed
the idea that there's one
regular plural.
And then, there are a
couple of different kinds
of irregular plurals.
So, we have the word dog.
Then it becomes dogs.
We have the word leaf.
Then it becomes leaves.
I'd like to introduce something
else too, the word child
is also an irregular plural
because its plural form
is not childs, but in fact, you ready,
say it with me, children.
Wow.
That's weird.
What is that about?
Like I said, English is
not a predictable language.
Few languages are.
When we think of English
as one solid block of wood,
what we're actually seeing
is this lashed together raft
made of spit, hope, and history.
So, it's your job as a writer
and a speaker of English
to make of this crooked
timber something straight,
to borrow a phrase and then mangle it.
So, the question is what is the deal?
Right.
And the answer is that it has
to do with English language
history and heritage.
English comes to us from Old English,
which, if you look at it now,
it kinda looks like German
because English is a Germanic language.
That's the term linguists use.
So, in Old English, there
were a bunch of different ways
to make something plural.
Some nouns would become
plural by adding an e n.
Some you could add an s.
Some you would add an r.
And part of this depended on
what part of England you lived
in at the time.
There were a bunch of
different regional variations.
Today, this e n ending only
applies to basically three
or four words.
These are all you need to
remember for this one weird
e n thing.
So, the e n ending plural only applies to
child,
ox,
brother, or sister.
And even those, these are really rare.
I bet you don't even know
what I'm talking about.
The plural of brother
originally was brethren.
The plural of sister
is sistren, or sistren.
But these are so rare, and
brothers and sisters is
so common that we don't
even need to consider them.
So, really, the only weird e
n plurals that are gonna be
in common usage are children, and oxen.
And unless your family
raises musk oxen or you're
an ox driver, you're probably
not gonna be using the word
ox very often, and if oxen
are a big part of your life,
you probably knew how to
pluralize them already
just from hearing people
talk about them your
entire childhood.
So, I'm going to cross that off too.
The only thing you need
to worry about is the e n
in children.
Child becomes children.
Now, you're probably wondering
David if there's the word ox,
and ox becomes oxen.
What about box?
Why is the plural of
box boxes and not boxen?
To borrow a gag from Brian Regan.
The simple truth is that it has to do with
this word's origin.
Ox is a native Old English word.
Box comes to us originally
from Greek, and then Latin.
And then French.
That's how it came to English.
I'm sorry if that's not a very
satisfying answer, but that's
how English works.
English is this language
that is composed of a bunch
of different puzzle pieces
all mashed together by time,
history, and repeated invasions,
which are totally metal.
But I'm getting away from myself.
The important thing to
remember is that for this
irregular plural, this e n
ending, really, unless you work
with oxen, or unless you are
leading some sort of old-timey
folk revival where you
have to refer to brethren
and sistren, child to
children is really the only
change you need concern yourself with.
All this can be summed up just like that.
You can learn anything.
David out.
Now, if you're still with
me, I would like to relate
a humorous, historical
anecdote that comes to us from
the 15th century English
printer William Caxton.
Now, this story comes to us
from about the year 1490.
And I just want to use this
story to illustrate just
how different, how dependent
on what part of the country
you were living in was on
the language that you spoke.
Because before mass transit,
and mass communication
media, which William Caxton
was a part of because he was
one of the first English
language printers.
Before any of this technology
allowed us all to communicate
with each other, we basically
just had letters, and most
people were illiterate.
And talking to each other.
And since it wasn't really
easy to get from place to place
to place before the advent
of cars most people didn't
really go very far.
So, here is the story, which
I will translate for you
from Middle English.
It goes like this.
So, these merchants were
traveling from the Thames river,
which flows through London,
and they're trying to get
to Zeeland, here, which is in
the modern day Netherlands.
This is, incidentally, this is England.
This is the southern
southeast coast of England.
They're trying to get to
Zeeland, and this is a distance
of about 160 miles.
Give or take.
But they can't make it
there because of bad winds.
They stop here at Foreland
to refresh their stores.
They stop for groceries basically.
And then, they realize that
their London English and the
English of the place where they are,
which is maybe 60 miles
out of London, maybe,
is mutually incomprehensible.
A man goes into a house.
Asks the woman of the house for eggs.
She doesn't understand the
word eggs because the word
she uses for eggs is eyren.
The word egg is Norse.
And he says I would like some egges.
And she says I don't have any egges.
I don't speak French.
And he gets angry because
he's like I don't speak
French either.
I'm English.
He says do you have any eggs.
She says I don't know what that is.
And finally, someone says
I think he means eyren.
Do you have any eyren?
And she said oh eyren.
Of course, here.
Buy some.
And it just goes to show
you that before the advent
of mass communication, we
could have had variations
from, as Caxton put it,
shire to shire to shire.
Each little town had its own
variant of language, and it
wasn't until everything was
united by this technology
that Caxton worked with, the
printing press, that people
started to become literate
and converge toward what
we would consider a more
unified standard of English.
Alright.
That was just a little bonus, silly video.
You can learn anything.
David out.